do
i have a good life in afghanistan
for me was a bit case seemed to be by
the taliban
so i could have we faith on
and i'm going it's week and i have
to go to europe away from acquaintance' or
i should go with  taiwan
help en
[Music]
i have no idea and i had no
information that what to go to
europe how europe
new people and new cultures new
languages ​​was
so very hard
[Music]
maybe forty-two for the 3d was quarter
rock of afghanistan  and i came
to pakistan first then via pakistan we
come to here
then durkje from turk and we come to
grace
yes and who you grace we come to europe
almost two years in year one and nine or
ten month month i lived and center
i  wait and for the the news that what
decision of commissariat was very
hard times dance for me
[Music]
that person I knew were at
the center who said I already have someone
who could match that my
personality who then so
v  esting has to work in order
to move forward in life but at a
quarter to seven there was now washing here
in such dirty clothes was so nervous
and so motivated to get to know
that it was already more important than before take
it easy  to wash and to change
clothes and the introduction that being in love
with hands and feet is a bit
dutch was very limited but there was
enough to see that was very
motivated i have with very big stone face
moment was
yes i want to work yes you can  do everything then
minus was put in prescription for me then
your sentence that
said yes yes of course I learned
[Music]
the first day I have started my
work interpretation was good but that work
was very difficult for me
well not ever nothing but not  all was
very difficult for me
i have ambition i always want to compromise
step in for him move on
maybe i will also
spiritual pens and once curious easy
rm future and born also
hello hello what are you doing  l joost
with searching water is in particular we see a
bit busy with chocolate
making one
I'm looking for a house find it's very
difficult well okay I research and find a
house within six men so I'm looking but I
have nothing just fat and they are expensive
so anton so very difficult
that someone has a chance at a
new life is a bonus of course and
i never thought beforehand that i
would ever take on a refugee and we went out
together in the evenings at the end
have to say that sultry and instructive
process and and  the idea in doing so gives someone a
new future street was bonus
to the ship me and john stan i ca
n't speak dutch knowledge recognize a lot of
people and i can very well work
and you
and my idea is that everyone should
feel human we are all people
who  allah where people someone is
catholic someone so islam someone is he
from afghanistan someone is from iraq
all is people at must think like that and
always that wk not
i am for someone with  who does
[Music]
is ok and then can talk